[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
dexter new blood episode 5 run away
so i want to make a disclaimer real
quick about this so as a person who gets
screeners early for shows like this
we were sent the first four episodes
like two months ago so when you saw my
reviews coming out weekly of episodes
one through four
those were recorded a while ago right so
i actually haven't watched the show in a
while because they told us that then
that episode five was going to come out
the week of the show coming out so
it just
arrived the screener about a week before
the premiere that you saw
just now but
it's always interesting because as a
critic you're like okay why are they
holding that fifth episode usually it's
because maybe they don't want something
spoiled that's a big turning point and
there's the other case where it's not as
strong as the others
and
they don't want that being reviewed in
the first batch when we give our season
score so
i was curious about that now
i'm gonna go with the latter saying that
it wasn't as strong as the others and
there's some serious problems in this
episode and i'm going to defend my case
on why i think that
and
what i want to say about this episode of
television in particular is that
i feel like when people comment on a
show and they don't like it or an
episode show or a movie they always say
things are contrived i think that's
overused and sometimes too harsh of a
claim on shows because that's going to
happen in shows and movies a lot no
matter how you try to avoid it
but this was a case where this was
insanely contrived this episode there
were so many moments that felt
artificial and forced in to have
something happen that needed to happen
um and
it was criminal in a sense so i will say
here that i defend that argument that
this was insanely contrived episode of
television um and i'll point those
moments out as we go through the episode
so we'll break it down i'll try to be as
fair as possible about it you know this
opening here with dexter and deb
it's interesting because she's like me
dexter's like maybe harrison came to me
so i can guide him so he's reflecting on
that right but what is interesting about
this episode is it kind of to me
is giving me a gut feeling that we're
developing
really this actual
feelings dexter dove does have for his
son because
he's feeling emotion about him and
wanting vengeance for him in this
episode and this love he actually does
have for harrison that he can feel this
um and it's a theme brought up when deb
even says to him you know this isn't
about the code or you know controlling
urges this is about vengeance here so
when we had debates in previous episodes
i saw a commenter saying that he's
full-on serial killer and that the code
is just there to guide him but he's not
someone who's a vigilante
i still think he's more complicated than
that but now we can confirm where he's
at now in the show yes he's now doing
this out of vengeance which maybe some
people won't like that turn they're
going with but i think it makes sense
but
what i feel from my gut of watching when
they're going with this is that they're
actually going to go a more breaking bad
end here um and root for this show uh
that
you know spoilers if you haven't seen
breaking bad leave now because i'm
talking about the end of breaking bad
but
basically that i feel like they are
rapping now dexter's story and that
we're gonna end what's happening michael
c all and that they want to fulfill a
better ending than the previous ending
of the show and that would be maybe
going the breaking bad route where
dexter gets
his comeuppings here
and
he does it in an honorable way that he's
gonna you know
take the fall for harrison and i think
they're also setting up the way they
wrote this episode to me is that
harrison is going to be
not what we think he is that he's not a
monster and that it's all a red herring
and it's just a tease and that it's
going to be some kind of turn that
harrison is actually more normal than we
think that's where
i'm feeling now at this point but going
into the episode number one on the
original screeners we got uh they didn't
have this thing where
at the beginning of the episode to show
you like this quick effect of scenes
that are going to come up in the episode
it's like what they do which i hate
trailers do now or there's a trailer for
the trailer it's like a trailer for the
episode inside the episode i hate that
takes me out of the story they didn't do
that in the first four screeners i don't
know if they've been doing it for the
show in general but they had it in this
episode and i hated it um
but maybe that's been happening all
season i'm not actually sure so let me
know i'm interested to hear that but
there's another issue here is that i
didn't see the trailer for episode five
so people tell me oh no kurt's
definitely the killer because we see in
the trailer he has chloe in that same
room so it's confirmed here that he is
the killer
okay i'm not so thrilled about that
we'll see where it goes but so far it's
boring me because now we know who the
killer is um
and that was obvious from the start then
because it was you know you saw with his
eye and that mask at episode one it was
probably kurt caldwell it is kirk
caldwell uh so
what's tough about this episode and
brings it down for me is that
even yes the point of this episode for
kurt's storyline with chloe here is to
see
kurt is having a case where it's not
going to plan to his ritual right this
girl is resisting the usual steps that
he gets to fall into his trap and have
them get sniped from far away right but
that's not the case here so it's
upsetting him you know it's not falling
to whatever he does where it's embalming
these bodies preserving them it messes
it up because he now shot this girl in
the eye but is it that interesting
no am i on the edge of my seat about
that stuff no do i really care
no and i think that comes from now we've
lost the mystery of who is this other
killer that is gone we know it's kurt so
you're kind of seeing like okay where
are they going with this kurt stuff um
clearly it's leading towards harrison
stuff which we'll get into but just with
his story alone with chloe i thought it
was just a lot of just okay great like
shoulder shrug i don't really care
because it's also blended with a story
that also is a problem to me in this
episode in particular was molly and
angela because
they're following a trail about matt but
we as the audience already know that
matt's not there that matt's dead so
there is a problem the show has run into
where you have two story lines in this
episode that were ahead of the
characters and you always have to be
careful when you're writing a story
where the audience is like way ahead of
the characters because now we're sitting
there waiting for them to catch up so
i'm sitting there like okay i'm just
waiting for angela to put the pieces
together that i already know so i can't
sit there in her shoes and relate and
feel like the suspense and mystery and
figuring out the case no it's like i'm
waiting for her to catch up to me which
is never something you really want to be
put into um there's a problem too
i thought it was bizarre you know we're
talking about contrived things that you
know chloe just happens to find a giant
piece of glass i guess under the pillow
in that room um i don't know if that's
from the first girl leaving there but
either way if it was or wasn't like he
would have cleaned the bed out he would
have saw that there's clearly this
weapon-like item under the pillow that
was ridiculous to me and i also make a
point too about the character of angela
i love this actress actually uh julia
jones i think she's really good but it's
just this weird thought i have in my
head i have to put it out somewhere that
she reminds me of marsha brady uh
character in the brady bunch spoof film
played by christine taylor i don't know
if it's the facial expressions or the
exact haircut
uh it's a very bizarre connection i have
my hand i have to get that out i'm
wondering if anyone else is feeling that
sure jan but
where there's another issue here in this
episode i'm stacking on a lot of
problems is i was worried i said in my
earlier reviews about you know when you
go into a teen story you got to be
really careful because you can get eye
rolls happening quick with dumb teens
and they leaned into it here which was
okay that fear is realized now and it
was going away from it keeping the
harrison story interesting but a lot of
cringe happening here with harrison
because
when you know i like the the story they
got going with dexter harrison right
that you know it's kind of showing us
like i'm saying my gut's telling me
harrison is not the bad guy because he's
saying he's upset his father is calling
him a liar when his he knows his
father's the liar uh but
you know when they pick him up right the
first thing that's just these doofy
teens and it's a killless party and now
we see okay that's what audrey has
decided to do
with the killer she found you know from
her mom which was just silly to me i
mean no one's taken seriously these
teams are partying about him saving
their lives when this is something that
would be pretty traumatic uh for them to
even just address
and they're like oh everyone's alive
here because of you and he's like this
hero at the party right where i thought
it was getting ridiculous is this blonde
just going to kiss him and says hey hero
you saved my life i was like oh my god
and then she's like oh and there's one
world this party no phones but they put
them all in this phone jar that's
totally accessible uh any good steal
which i thought was just silly too but
she's like what happens here stays here
and then she gives him ecstasy and of
course he takes it so he there's dumb
decision number one by harrison i get
he's emotional but this was just getting
absurd and
this always this really happens when
this girl you know asked him to carve an
h into her ankle because he's her hero i
was like oh man and you know
we're supposed to pay attention to his
reaction to the blood he kind of seems
stunned by it so it's not kind of like
the dexter reaction where he gets that
urge from craving from it but we got
this
drawn out sequence of being in
harrison's shoes when he's on these
pills and then he takes another pill and
is drinking beer like an idiot and he
takes an oxy which we'll find out is
actually fentanyl and this is where i'm
talking about a lot of contrived stuff
or maybe you can get away with one or
two in an episode but adding to it is
when he says to audrey my dad doesn't
believe me he thinks i'm a liar you know
he's the liar his real name isn't jim
lindsay you know and it was like oh god
like here we go and again just even
little things i thought were going to
try i was like
in my notes here i have dexter goes to
the pub right and
the whole purpose of tests the bartender
in this scene is to suggest harrison to
go to a therapist which is something
pretty extreme to just say right away at
the top of a conversation about the guy
who's looking as a hero in the town uh
and
you know we even see kurt just shows up
right at this time he's playing the song
he always plays and dances with tess
kind of telegraphing that she's probably
gonna be a victim soon
but again a lot of this just felt so
forced but we see when dexter shows up
to the hospital
to harrison who od'd here
you know he finds out his fentanyl so he
knows it's just like messed up drug
dealer who's basically killing people uh
selling this stuff and this makes him
feel that rage we're talking about where
he wants vengeance now this isn't just
about the code or urges it's his actual
love for harrison his son and where
dexter makes you know his criminal
mistake
as a father here he's trying to be a
good dad is trusting harrison to go to
this therapist by himself and leaving
him alone at the home because harrison
ends up deciding you know what i'm
leaving town again uh and
this is his kind of mo harrison he just
runs away i guess but
it sets up his actual therapy session
will be with kurt and the problem with
dexter leaving him alone after having an
od and having all these you know
mental issues he's clearly showing
is now he's running to kurt who's going
to be a problem for harrison and he was
warned dexter here by deb in his
conscience about don't like don't go on
this killing spree out of just
vengeance you know and
just killing in general it's never
working out for dexter and she's
constantly mentioning how that's caused
him all this messed up stuff in his life
already it never does good for him
because he goes now super relapse goes
to get his classic tools even for
killing but it's still even falcon try
this like yeah he goes to the animal
doctor in town you know and when i'm
talking about other stuff that just
seems so convenient like they're
stacking it on here right the
convenience like logan's showing up when
he goes to
kill this drug dealer and stabs him with
the syringe right on cue and then when
he goes to kill the top drug dealer
who's making the pills
logan shows up right on cue it's
constantly happening here where again
it's just too much
and even some of the writing was just
really taking me out of it that just
didn't feel realistic and that even
comes to yes when dexter shows up and is
staking out this first drug euro miles
and he meets him at the pub he's like
heard you might know where to get some
blues now i'm not saying drug dealers
are smart people here but this has to be
the dumbest drug dealer on the planet
because he doesn't even ask like how did
you hear about me or anything and this
guy dexter clearly looks like an
undercover cop he's asking the things an
undercover cop would ask and he just
goes with him so that to me was just not
earned and just not believable but if
there's one thing i loved about this
episode you know dexter is at jasper's
house and he's going to kill him and we
get the best line of the season where he
says hell i should just kill this guy
because of his wallpaper that was great
but it's so bizarre because it's
followed by probably the worst line of
the season where he sees jasper plays
video games and he's like he likes to
play games but i'm not here to play come
on
come on so before we go back to dexter's
story here in harrison i want to talk
about this conference angel batista is
at right
which is a huge reappearance of angel
from the original series
maybe he's a little rusty on the acting
but
i don't want to be you know too judging
on one episode but it wasn't the best
but angel brings up the trinity killer
case because this is a case of a cop
following their gut and deborah morgan
he's like she never gave up and she died
in the brother too tragic and then he
goes he had a little son and he's like
oh what was his name oh he goes oh yeah
harrison so again this is where
it's like feeling really just too easy
now and silly and it's feeling like a
soap opera how everything's just coming
tightly so easily for us to have angela
find out about dexter now like this
really made me roll my eyes the liner he
said you know harrison and cute kid
because
it leads up to when audrey reveals to
angela what harrison said that his dad's
name isn't jim lindsey and we get this
like soap opera reaction style
you know shot where it pushes in on
angela's reaction like she puts it all
together i was like oh my god
you're just a [ __ ]
[Music]
and yeah you're seeing how she probably
just went to the office looked up
deborah morgan's name to connect it to
harrison and see it's now dexter morgan
in the obituary this man that you know
angel mentioned had died and now sees
that's not jim lindsey which is a big
reveal but again it feels so contrived
to get to that the way it was revealed
was just so easy and even the way that
they made it that angel was just
happened to be at this hotel happened to
be his only purpose in this episode you
know was to get
angela that information about harrison
so
it's frustrating i thought they had been
a little more creative about angel being
put into the show and how angelo would
figure this all out about dexter what i
did like though in this episode was some
of the suspense here that was made with
dexter in these scenes with jasper on
the table that he's still sloppy dexter
and why i feel like again he's gonna
have his comeuppings at the end of this
show and he's just gonna take the fall
because he's not thinking it's clear
he's thinking more emotional when it
comes to harrison and see he has to have
jasper od here to cover up that he's
about to kill him his way that he wants
to but he's like i have to make
sacrifices as a parent don't get to
always do things the way we want but
make these small sacrifices for the good
of our children after all if we can't do
that we don't deserve to be parents i
like this writing here i like what
they're doing with him trying to be a
good
uh dad as a serial killer it's
interesting but
we see that you know on the other side
of things kurt is pulling up
to harrison and this is bad news and we
know kurt has had harrison and dex on
his radar it's more of harrison leading
him to dexter he's suspicious of like he
had this droney give harrison which is
definitely gonna come back but you know
there's a reason kurt is there meeting
with harrison he's on to them not really
harrison doesn't really do anything in
that department with matt but he's
clearly out for dexter i'm going to give
a shout out to one of my favorite
subscribers and commenters who's moving
me for the longest time subversively
surreal because she mentioned about
harrison's eating that was pretty much
torture listening to it last episode and
i thought that while i was watching so
props because i totally agree and we got
that at full force in this diner scene
man it's like i just feel like the
character of harrison you know he's
eating like it's the first time he's
ever had a plate of food like in his
life it's intense it's that that chewing
is brutal
i'm starving but harrison to get a
therapy session here from kurt kind is
the reason he's staying in town now so
we'll see where this goes but
i was like really disappointed in this
episode i'm going to give it a 5.9
it's not a lower score even though i'm
complaining a lot about things i didn't
like um because i did think there was
good moments with dexter and his story
as being a dad and there was suspense
here with the moments
with him killing jasper
but everything else
was problematic to me and um i hope it
can get back on its feet the next
episode uh maybe you feel completely
different this is what happens with
shows like this right and that's why we
debate but this is how i felt um i don't
want to feel this way i want to love
this show and i usually do
but this was
just really not good to me
but let me know what you thought down
below i love to hear your thoughts i
read every comment i try to respond as
many as i can uh please make sure to
subscribe don't miss one of my reviews
of dexter i'm also doing the wheel of
time i also just celebrate interviews if
you want to check that out uh and please
follow me at steveharleyshow on twitter
and instagram for more of me and i'll
see you next time